[Music]
a ring celebrating a special achievement
makes a cherished lifelong keepsake
whether it's a classroom to commemorate
graduation from high school or a
championship ring for the players on a
winning sports team
as the years go by this special piece of
jewelry keeps the memories close at hand
championship rings are entirely custom
made they typically feature the team
name and logo along with the year of the
big win
they can also have personalized touches
such as the player's name or jersey
number
class rings on the other hand come in
several ready-made designs presented in
a catalog
graduates order their favorite style
then personalize their ring by choosing
options such as symbols gemstones and
engraved lettering
for each style a jewelry designer first
sketches the ring's base
the overall shape of the ring minus the
decorative elements then an industrial
designer transforms the sketch into a
three-dimensional computer drawing
the ring's decorative components go
through the same process
the jewelry designer's color drawing
adapted to 3d software that guides a
computer-operated milling machine
[Music]
the machine transforms two blocks of
aluminum into a two-part mold for each
of the flat detailed components of the
ring meaning all the parts except for
the base
a steady flow of lubricant washes away
the shards of metal the machine cuts
away
bit by bit the mold assumes very
intricate detail of the ring design
once it's finished they coat the cavity
with the powder that prevents the wax
they're about to inject from sticking
then they load the mold into an
injection device it shoots in hot liquid
wax at high pressure filling all the
minute nooks and crannies of the
intricately detailed cavity
seconds later they extract a wax model
of in this case the elaborate top of a
championship ring
to make a wax model of the ring's base
they use a flexible rubber mold because
it would be too difficult to extract the
three-dimensional shape from a metal
mold
they inject the wax at low pressure as a
rubber mold can't withstand high
pressure injection
nor is it necessary when the base has no
intricate details
[Music]
the next step is to assemble the wax
models of two of the rings components
connecting the parts with joining wax
applied using a fine tip soldering iron
it's at this stage that they also size
the ring for the customer
either cutting out a section of the
shank to downsize or adding to the shank
to enlarge
next they begin building a wax structure
on which to mount the wax models for
several rings they'll be casting
simultaneously
they solder a small stem to each model
then connect each stem to a large wax
rod
when they're done they have a tree-like
structure holding all the wax models
they solder this structure to a rubber
base
then slip a metal flask over it
next they mix up some plaster blending
it for a good half hour under a vacuum
to remove all the air bubbles
then they inject the plaster into the
flask engulfing the wax models and
supporting structure inside over the
next 12 hours the plaster hardens into a
shell around the wax
next 12 hours in a hot oven
this burns out the wax components
leaving behind a cavity in the shell
shaped precisely like them
[Music]
now it's just a matter of melting down
the metal for the final casting
[Music]
the technique of using a wax model to
create a mold is known as the lost wax
process
this company uses the plaster shell as a
mold to cast rings in three types of
metal gold sterling silver and stainless
steel
regardless of the metal the ring making
process is the same
in just minutes the induction furnace
has heated the metal in this case gold
to the required molten state
they carefully pour it into the plaster
shell
gold flows down channels and into
cavities left when the wax burnt out
once the gold cools and solidifies they
submerge the shell in cool water
this instantly dissolves the hot plaster
releasing the cast piece
everything that was once modeled in wax
is now replicated in gold
they cut the ring components off the
structure then re-melt the structure to
reuse the gold
there's still a remnant of the structure
on each ring component so they grind it
off
next using a grinding tool so small that
it fits through the ring they smooth the
inside surface
then they stamp in the company name
along with the internationally
recognized code identifying the metal
such as 10k for 10k gold
to smooth the ring's outer surface they
use a grinding wheel which has splits in
its abrasive discs
the split produces a see-through view as
the discs spin at high speed
with the entire surface now smooth the
ring is ready for polishing
they apply some polishing compound then
using another split wheel shine it up
next the top of the ring goes to the
stone setting department
where using a fine rotary tool a
specialist contours each setting to fit
the gemstone's pointed base
then he sets each gemstone
forcing down the four surrounding prongs
onto the edge of the stone
next he sets tiny diamonds
he presses each one into place then
pushes the surrounding metal inward to
hold the stone down
the top of the ring complete they now
solder it to the base
using an airbrush they apply a fine mist
of black paint then wipe it off
this leaves behind a black background
highlighting the ring's details
now they apply some polishing compound
to a cloth buffing wheel and polish the
ring to a high gloss shine
they clean the ring thoroughly in
repeated ultrasonic bass
ultrasound waves traveling through the
water dislodge all traces of polishing
compound and other residues
a few blasts of pressurized steam and
the ring is completely dry
certain rings also have enamel
decoration
enamel is liquid glass
it goes on like paint
then has to be baked in an oven for 30
minutes
finally a computer-guided engraving
machine inscribes any name or personal
message customers request be written on
or inside their rings
the tradition of the class ring dates
back to the 1800s championship rings a
wearable trophy of sorts are a more
recent custom
both make a proud and triumphant fashion
statement
[Music]
you